is there a minimum
what figure yeah I mean because yeah to
be honest let's be honest because he's
unemployed if he's unemployed for two
years you're out yeah probably
yeah he's unemployed for Tears I'm out
but so there has to be like a minimum
what would you roughly say it is
I couldn't I don't know what people earn
and not shift work I couldn't tell you
how much you'd like him
not shift work like what would you like
him to bring I'm a month yeah in a month
two grand three grand
four grand remember you you listen if he
says quit whatever the amount that
sustains us to like be happy but I don't
need like big fleshy things to be happy
if you'd be happy living in the Caravan